last week I asked Optima stories of your
lives about people who did you wrong and
some of your lives are good number Fredo
I'm gonna help y'all now holla
[Music]
contestant number one Peters Oh Lord
that's not your real name is it
my story is I hated this guy thought he
was mr. perfect as he texts me every
morning before you go to work and do all
that sweet things a boyfriend would do
so I say the extra faithful and became
super attached to figure out that he
only wanted to date me because he wanted
mouth read card and because I said no
it's too soon he started cheating on me
telling me he wants someone who would
know how to use him and that he's like a
card that can't be kept in the garage at
all times he force me to do things that
I felt very uncomfortable doing and if I
didn't do it
we will start a fight I feel dumb but
letting him take me over like that let
me tell you something you sample the
milk and now you think you would have
the whole [ __ ] be calm for you
obviously helping yourself a venereal
disease yet dirty ass filthy McNasty huh
what was it you can't be kept in the
garage at all times
it ain't my fault you ain't enough with
the run [ __ ] you think what take it out
if dirty pizza let's look your mom start
fights for me cuz you wanted some
cookies out the cookie jar did you ever
think for once that maybe I don't want
you then maybe I'm tired then maybe
you're not good at what you think you
got that huh breaking up with me was the
best thing you have biggest two more
weeks with your ugly abused the best i
wanna chop yo that's number two kevin
day that's less next day
[Music]
excuse me uh what's going on here Oh
oh you're breaking up with me oh you
know what it's all good it's all good
girl because I have expended your ugly
ass was traveling anyways what was it if
you're so ugly why I don't want to be
with your trifling ass a charity before
you straight up a biscuit the other day
guess I'm in love with that [ __ ] too
huh
let me tell you something that I taught
me you girl oh yes I'm talking to your
new man over here her titties are
lopsided her breath smells like bamboo
shoots and she pots up a storm in her
sleep so good luck with that and I hope
you baby come across my [ __ ] this
actually has nothing to do with anything
but a Stevens al orzo damn agent named
Kent that's my [ __ ]
I had a girlfriend and I introduced her
to one of your videos she didn't find it
funny at all so I'm problem with that
the next day contestant number 3 Sarah
grace Jannes wrote so I live with this
chick was about two years older than me
an apartment that we both went her down
so when I first moved in her boyfriend
was there and that's how long he was
going to be there and she said Oh a
couple of days a couple of days turn
into months and months of him never
paying rent or utilities or anything
anyways I left for a couple months to go
work out in Orlando and I stayed with my
parents and I was hoping to get my stuff
a month ago because we attended the same
school and she was now graduating I went
back to the apartment to grab my things
only to find that when we got there she
had stolen all my things
then dance doors DVD CDs iPods of my
life and etc over $5,000 worth of my
things first of all you don't bring your
smelly ass dirty no job hasn't free load
of boyfriend up in my place and spend it
up I was nice enough to not want to tell
you this [ __ ] but your boyfriend was
cheating on you when I came over at
night and he was screaming somebody just
named that wasn't yours [ __ ]
and how many milk times do I tell you I
don't like drugs what you know Ann said
it means do I got to do I can access it
for you do I have to say it in Korean
Jess come up
she bunny to tell me to defeat you mine
in Akane to 190 much I'm gonna remember
I told you I used to have a little
brother he's stalking me guess what he's
now he dead no you know what no get up
yeah I am
person but I'm a you buck girl I hope
I'll meet you inside I'm a grocery store
Long Beach at the back of oranges back
to the Antoine Dobson hide your kids
hide your wife cuz I'm coming with you
anyways YouTube this concludes this
month's version of people's haters so if
you want to get involved with this I
want to tell me your story I'll be
putting up another post to allow you to
go ahead and do that here's a couple
tips number one if you don't write me a
story
make sure it's less than 4 pages long
number 2 spell check the [ __ ] cuz I
don't want to have to figure out what
you're trying to say to me oh 1 days I'm
a ho it's a broken it's a so many pieces
[Music]
notice the latino man in the diaper only
in the streets of LA I don't need any
underwear bubble sometimes you just
can't go to the bathroom